jazz in the old town of the Georgian
capital Tbilisi for many Georgians the
musical style symbolizes a western
lifestyle and personal freedoms
this club is a popular meeting place and
a favorite of Martina Schwarz an advisor
to German businesses operating in
Georgia the country in the Caucasus is
looking westwards
yes it's very Western oriented
increasingly so Europe days are held
here Europe does a lot here which
strengthens pro-european sentiment in
the population whatever photo georgia
hopes to join the European Union since
the country signed a free trade deal
with the EU last year many trade ties
have been established sports works for
the German business association whose
members include some 140 Georgian and
German firms she's on her way to one of
Georgia's largest construction sites
here they're creating a commercial strip
thought to be the biggest in the
southern Caucasus it's a great business
opportunity for German manufacturer
canal it's supplying the drywall for the
interiors now--if employs over 100
people in the country making it one of
the biggest German investors here
Georgia's economy grew by around 4.7
percent last year and the construction
industry was a major contributor but for
canals general director for marketing
here the Georgian market alone is too
small he hopes to sell the company's
drywall to firms in neighboring
countries as well gaining access to
markets in Western Europe has given the
entire Georgian economy a boost have
more money now they're more motivated to
find investors or found their own
businesses people are earning more
because the Free Trade Agreement makes
it easier to sell the goods produced
here in Europe and that's a great
motivation
Martyna Schwartz's next appointment is
at a brewery she often establishes
contacts between German and Georgian
companies this brewery purchased all of
its equipment from Germany and even
produces a few brands of German beer
under license to comply with Germany's
purity law the only ingredients used are
water
malted barley and hops workers here earn
around 450 euros a month that's more
than the statutory minimum wage but much
less than people earn elsewhere in
Europe most Georgians are in favor of
establishing closer ties with the EU
people expect it would give them a
better life and a higher standard of
living our country has good future
prospects with the EU and we can take
heart in the fact that things will get
better now we know where we belong along
with beer the brewery also makes sweet
carbonated drinks management is planning
to bring a new flavor onto the market
based on a traditional Georgian recipe
the organ mr. Georgia produces many
kinds of different carbonated drinks and
they drink them all the time
this is their latest innovation
chocolate cream
not even the brewery got its start with
a loan from the European Bank for
Reconstruction and Development
last year the EBRD loaned out some 214
million euros to help Georgia modernize
at its annual meeting the bank's
director for the Caucasus Moldova and
Belarus explains what needs to be done
he needs to transcend its institutions
he need to strengthen also its
regulatory body and in general he needs
to do to continue modernizing the
economy bringing new technologies making
its economy more competitive and attract
investments also to improve improve
employment I think Georgia is doing the
right thing but Martina shvarts says it
will take years before these positive
changes will be felt by the general
population reforms are underway but
Georgia still has a long way to go